you got a lot of other people who love
you because you had your hustlers
co-star came up high yeah this was here
okay so JLo and Constance Wu seem to be
on fine terms but new report suggests
Constance has been diva when it comes to
their new movie hustlers and that she
demanded top billing
for the movie Constance does have top
billing to the trailer which does seem a
little weird since JLo not only stars in
the movie but she also produced it but
Constance is shutting down rumors that
that had anything to do with her in a
new statement her rep tells et quote
while Constance is character in hustlers
is the key protagonist any reporting
that implies or indicates that she
demanded or directed this recently
reported initiative is patently untrue
and a clear manipulation of facts a lot
to unpack there but that's not following
claims that our team with emailing press
outlets to ensure she was listed as the
headliner in their coverage of the movie
et has learned people did reach out to
media outlets to correct
misrepresentations of the film's
characters and casting in the spirit of
calibrating credits to accurately
reflect the guidelines set forth in
standard legal contracts
though Constance had no knowledge of
this last 40 percents 160
constant says rep also says she's been a
a proud supporter of her fellow
castmates inclusion in the celebration
of this film and her co-stars are big
stars
aside from JLo we have Julia Stiles Lily
reinhardt's Liz o keke palmer and yeah
cardi B who told et that JLo was so
involved she was the one to help cast
her how did that come about - JLo call
you did you call her but she first spoke
to my team and due to the fact that I
got to work on my album I got like a
little smaller role even though my
schedule was busy like it's like I had
to be in this movie like this movie is
something that I could relate this was
my life and it's just like yeah yeah but
back to Constance this isn't the first
time she's been hit with diva rumors
after her series fresh-off-the-boat got
renewed which is usually something to
celebrate she went off on Twitter
writing things like inhale and so upset
right now that I'm literally crying ah
Constance apologized after all that and
said she was just upset she had to give
up another project
she was really passionate about all I
know is even with all of this drama I'm
so excited for hustlers and clearly the
cast is too I love this character I love
the story it's just real life the things
like actresses dream up be able to
produce a tenth store and it was real
special I mean it was really freaking
cool to be a part of all these badass
women what can you say about your
character what can you teach you get all
your get all dean 800 alright guys what
do you think of all this news about
Constance and are you is ready to see
hustlers when it hits theaters later
this year as I am let me know all your
thoughts and for all the latest keep it
locked on all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and
now